[Applaudissements]
20 il est morte à battice à lui et au
jones est revenu et on est à une heure
de tournage sur 200 ex que c'est bon
dieu de nous est ce que c'est bon pour
mes amis vous savez pour qu'on est là
vous avez vu le clip
mais au moment où je tourne je n'ai pas
fait ce voyage je n'ai pas vu tous ces
gens on va commencer avec paris je le
rappelle c'est commencer maintenant
petit rappel du concept nous allons
faire une surprise à plusieurs abonnés à
travers toute la francophonie à chaque
fois un proche de la personne est dans
le coup et on commence aujourd'hui avec
williams qui a 31 ans qui habite à paris
sa copine est dans le coup on va le
réveiller
alors c'est parti les guerres n'est pas
et on va lui amener le petit déj égard
3 à l'étagé
comme diraient nos jeunes
plus et là bas sera nommé dimanche ici
jean stressant
[Musique]
cédric robin gilbert qui m'a fils un
premier baiser ou merveilleux je me tais
pas c'est qu'ils cherchent des solutions
extrêmes des gens va être chaud thé dans
la gamme on va y aller en fait on fait
vivre un enfer un mec qui entamait le
petit déj et éduquer à savoir ni les
conditions ni s'était passé à porter
merci mais comme un passage en un
instant après l'évasion je suis jours on
va chez toi j'ai envie de marcher très
avancé
les jeunes histoire qu'on soit athée
jalouse abbas attend chiba à toi c'est
un chinois nous ont dit envisager faire
une portée on est peut-être avec la
future aujourd'hui qu'on bat en gros la
apprennent on va aller à l'air au sol
face tu connais c'est un endroit on peut
tags et on va attaquer le logo de la
chaîne s'est vu que c'est une
illustration
non ce que m'a dit je me rends propagera
à ma meuf qui prépare un truc pour la
finale de coupe du monde
on va là matteo jardins suspendus et on
est sûr qu'ils ont gagné tu es pour la
croatie imaginons qu'on saura droite
[Musique]
william on vient d'arriver à l'aérosol
on va rencontrer un graffeur trop occupé
pour graffer mon logo sur le mur on est
avec synthèse les amis et comment ça va
ouais et lucas mon mec tu vas faire le
logo du coup tu m'as envoyé tour logo
c'est tout le temps dans une image et tu
fais en live tu vas commencer par faire
du coup de tête
une esquisse tu m'as dit voilà il
esquisse comme si on commence au crayon
de papier sur un vitrail
pourquoi donc nous on va pouvoir
registre en clair un peu et même
beaucoup des mêmes maux tout ce qui est
suite à un concours quasiment entre
garde faire ça c'est parti
[Musique]
vous avez reconnu
c'est à ce même endroit qu'on avait
tourné huit mois plus tôt le clip de ce
top 10 des jeux de l'année avec cyprien
[Musique]
williams a dû sentir sa chienne comme
chaque dimanche et deux heures plus tard
ils se retrouvent l'attaqué avec moi
vous vous en doutez on a passé la
plupart de vote soit parler de nos
chiens je le suspecte d'être aussi gaga
que moi si ce n'est plus
je suis accro j'adore cet honneur
[Musique]
ça m'a fait beaucoup de bien passer du
temps avec lui étant donné qu'il a plus
d'expérience que moi sur pas mal de
choses de la vie trentenaire oblige et
plus simplement parce que c'est un mec
génial mais on a contribué à ça alors
mais installé on peut plus l'arrêter
radio est lancée plus tôt fait de garder
ça c'est entièrement grâce à - william
merci quand même pour ta petite aide au
centre et ça c'est cool mec c'est
incroyable le instagram de santé
s'affiche ici tribunal estime mec c'est
fou c'est
[Applaudissements]
là
à la pronostiquent match
moi je pense qu'on leur met 3 0 1 0 4 2
pour la france si tur 0 sextuplé crise
[Musique]
mon ami william nom n'est pas en couleur
alors même que j'ai acheté de quoi faire
je t'ai pris un petit maillot du drapeau
des lunettes des bracelets mais qu'on
met la panoplie du supporter al jazeera
se poser leurs adversaires c'est le
moment on découvre son corps d'athlète
juste derrière toi ben arfa je m'en bats
les couilles à william illat hyper mais
là il a pas encore de ouf
[Musique]
renault vient vers la mer voilà bah oui
martin bien tout le monde y passe les
gars je suis désolé
et voilà jazzman il a senti si l'un
d'eux se passe je te jure regarde bien
il a fait une passe décisive
vous tenez ça depuis que j'ai les
drapeaux sur les joues je suis trop
investi là
[Applaudissements]
urgent
[Musique]
tout comme ça
des bus un streaming chalet
ap
mais c'est toujours c'est là
une équipe est en danger
la tête de versailles
l'égalisation ils demandent une main les
français il a le bras décollé du corps
en tout six minutes
[Applaudissements]
ap ap derrière lui il n'y a pas
si la pays face à vidal
[Applaudissements]
une petite fille
ça fait 4 2 mais qu'est ce que c'est
cette fine entrer dans leurs mains les
supporteurs croates
petite minute en minute
trois minutes
dominique syrien de minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a gagné
les choses amères williams et merci pour
cette journée c'était génial de ou
vraiment quand tu veux on sent de chiba
en sont en effet copuler ont fait des
bébés dans l'euphorie de la victoire
c'est n'importe quoi c'est incroyable ça
va merci mon gars on a [ __ ] le game 7
coupe du monde en ayant rien fait parce
que nos justes en garde prochaine étape
c'est nantes pour moi ça m'a fait trop
besoin de te rencontrer mac et puis elle
que tu as toi dans tes projets dans tout
ça et c'est merci tout âge ça fait un
câlin merci pièce
[Musique]
à
mais 7h10 des faux mails et 7h40 sonné
quand même ça pique go donc tu quand on
a eu la peau mate as-tu le temps chaud
ensuite on prend la tête de l'individu
on a pas qu'au sol comme ceux ci est là
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est terminé la
notion résout le problème
voilà vous n'êtes pas d'individus merci
mais la magie vaudou d'apprendre et
merci lui
[Musique]
mes amis nous sommes avec lawrence quand
tu vois je suis trop content merci de
nous avoir permis de turquie si dame en
vaux charlène qu'on va aller voir tout
de suite qui dort très profondément
apparemment soit versé que tu vas
rentrer avant nous tu ferme la porte tu
dis habitants ensuite elle s'habille et
non au taquet en dessous ok on y va on y
va zy je te suis ses sortilèges
il
devant laurens van le parti
[Musique]
bah oui mais je t'attends tu es bizarre
le fonds et ses rivaux ibériques
comment ça on est venu avec lawrence à
les complices de toutes les merdes
direct on va galérer
on voit ça tourne ensemble on va aller à
un endroit qui s'appelle la machine
géniale
merci beaucoup htc beaucoup cette époque
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
le carrousel des mondes marins déjà venu
ici ouais n'était jamais rentré
non tu aimes et la tour eiffel à paris
c'est ça c'est une chose qui nous ouvre
le lieu aujourd'hui
juste pour mémoire sa magnifique
aventure va quitter ce parti yes bâton
qui souffre du couffo lui certains
qu'ils ont lancé sur le côté au dessus
des partis
alors bienvenue au carrousel des mondes
marins merci beaucoup on entendrait tous
se lancent à chaque fois c'est rien pour
vous là on est juste avant l'ouverture
au public à 10 heures manquantes
profitez-en
regardez bien choisissez c'est à vous de
monter après cela la gauche molle
inquiète franchement rien le bateau
il est incroyable thema avec la vapeur
il est tellement stylet on est obligé de
faire ça ok j'étais d'accord donc deux
choisissait le cap et c'est parti
lassana bnr tamesloht à vient de
devancer moi qui prends tout mais c'est
incroyable c'est sûr pas je gouverne on
s'en prend par ailleurs c'est sûr c'est
ma vie mon foot assume c'est toi qui a
eu l'idée brusque nom chinois guide
spielberg et or noir
il faut absolument vincent collet je
veux toutes les essayer a passé l'âge
là on va faire le plus long de tous
après on va être à l'aise et style et
c'est parti yes we say party alors
puisque vous êtes jaloux de notre style
a tous les deux ont des cours semble la
position foetale charlene j'ai apprécié
ce moment ça aurait été comme ça et ça
nous pas il ya plein de mouvements
s'affoler mais pour votre série no 2
avant d'être âge il ya 20 ans nourrit
qui fait là
oh
[Musique]
charlène ce moment carrousel était
génial maintenant on va embarquer dans
l'éléphant qu'on a vus faire le tour
donnant enfin le tour d'un tout petit
bout de ce qu'il avance à deux
kilomètres à 7 100 m alain bernard va
plus vite c'est malin parce qu'à mon
avis ça le rend encore plus gigantesque
et à la baisse de choses très petites
comme antoine donc très différent la
pire borea chanel en a rien à [ __ ]
elles sont pas les couilles ça me passe
la plus dure et ce n'est jamais évident
qu est ce bien un autre l'avoir charlaté
elle s'en bat les couilles mais vu ça
j'ai autant de la divertir les chicago
bulls elle passe un meilleur moment du
film et c'est dans la boîte
oh [ __ ] théo alors jallet n'a été ni
vertu c'est bon puis il est meilleur que
toi tu rates un marine petit mec j'ai
pris la chose c'est terminé on est sur
une en général les fans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier mais qui m'a envoyé un mail pour
dire qu'il m'avait vu tout à l'heure
quand on était devant le carrousel
il est des glaces qui nous a raté son
mail s'appelle nantes sommes revus ça
annonce la couleur et fort regret ne pas
avoir saisi l'opportunité de prendre en
photo avec toi sur un nombre ce matin le
17 juillet le manque de courage était
présent et je n'osais pas déranger toute
l'équipe technique autour qui te fait
mais peut-être il ya beaucoup de doutes
et de manque de couilles dans ce message
fait d'offre voici mon numéro qu'on
l'appelle bas c'est dommage pour mathieu
mois salut séchage ou rappel sur ce
numéro
allez on t'aime on va manger oui c'est
parti charlène ouais on est avec tes
amis et l'invité surprise
il a envoyé son mail et ça a marché il
avec nous georges tant qu il est là au
loin je vois une perche et là je vois un
petit bonhomme
ai-je fait fait aux noces et squeeze je
suis quoi je suis qu'au début de la fin
du genre je suis le seul petit bonhomme
non non non c'est comme ma venue à
l'ailé ces nouvelles caméras cassées
cassez vous
[Musique]
mr foncier bâti à bientôt sur youtube
artigau
nous venons d'arriver au fleuve jaune
solaire sur l'herbe
j'avais geste et j'ai vu la carte et toi
bon on doit faire du paddle
j'arrive il me sort d'une anecdote qui
m'a refroidi direct le paddle s'est
transformé en bateau motorisé ils m'ont
dit oui on a des potes qui sont baignés
qu'ils ont bu la tasse ce monsieur n'à
jamais pendant deux semaines terminées
jamais bateau ça vous va alors qu'est ce
qu'on attend
les amis nous voici pause et humiliante
acheter avec youtube mois de rigoler ma
coûtait pas cher son bateau c'est en
moins vingt balles
mettez vous bien et là mais j'ai acheté
riotte est bien là ou pas ok mais non tu
es préféré ils sont là
on a passé près de deux heures sur ce
bateau avec charlène et ses potes nos
discussions m'ont fait beaucoup de bien
parce qu'elles m'ont rappelé une fois de
plus à quel point ma vie n'est pas
normal à quel point je fais rien comme
les gens de mon âge j'ai beaucoup de
chance et vous le savez déjà versé
entièrement grâce à vous alors je le
dirai jamais assez merci les amis on est
dans ce bateau nous tranquilles et un
polo castle d'anciens mec je suis sûr
qu'ils méditent sur la vie rurale
on dirait un taxi bateau devenu ce pôle
en patates la musique ça le chien bon
lucas c'est sympa sur ton bateau mais
chez pour l'eau il ya beaucoup
d'ambiance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est cool tu vois on vient on fait
le tour de france est tout paulo ils
s'enjaillent avec les gens ça me casse
les couilles tu vois en pensez quoi vous
[Musique]
cette journée est terminée visa sur une
petit short que c'est ça ça c'est pour
notre école pour nous avoir autorisés à
être là merci la mgm graphic design
d'avoir accepté de lâcher vos élèves
pour ma vidéo c'est très aimable vous
aurez en échange
aucun revenu ces derniers découvrent sa
journée au bar et surtout le bateau mais
la chose là les nantais goudé chef vous
êtes trop merci pure ambiance c'était
trop bien je me suis éclatée ça fait
trop plaisir de parler avec vous enfin
jusqu'à un collectif
[Musique]
et
hugo boss est ce que tu peux nous dire
qu'il varie les lucas et 4,56 on va
faire quoi on va surprendre
un belge de la bonne montgolfière avec
lui et va être dans le même état que
nous maintenant si les plans sont sous
l'eau aujourd'hui c'est normal 2 allez
c'est parti
non
ex thomson bonjour ont changé bonjour
selvi on a besoin de faire tout sauf la
vidéo des 10 millions c'est génial quand
on est devant chez nous et va le
réveiller ce qu il est 5 heures du matin
tu vas pas nous en vouloir moi quelqu'un
réveil à 5h même c'est brad pitt ça
vraiment ça dégage je m'en mords non
c'est pas grave j'adore rencontrer on y
va
comment ça va nous tuer nous y arrivons
à faire à la montgolfière mon gars tu as
fait tu vas te réveiller et à 15 minutes
après elle pour préparer et on va partir
ensemble votre chien des prêts au vote
en mars et à la mancelle qui complique
elle a touché les albums y voit une
genre dans sa chambre de marquer touché
un truc j'ai peur de l'amour cher mais
que ça monte à 500 mètres du sol et
c'est un ballon qui nous tient juste je
suis pas bien moins donc fonction du
courage ok tu te laisse te préparer à
les bahamas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi cette histoire de
doublage là je double emploi des fois
des trucs fait une série où je ferchiou
les disney il nous laisse passer les
inspectrices manquons est-ce qu'il ya
les inspecteurs des inspecteurs des
propres récits à une police des police
des polices tur bat enfin après jean
micoud paix tu vois on voir on fait un
truc je te réponds mais un policier du
corps policier le policier est amer et
plaisir tout comme un accord avec un
spectateur
auo non
[Musique]
mais ça ne s'est pas bien de dire des
coûts
[Musique]
- 48 kg on s'en fout ta d'hergé tout le
monde dit c'est triste ce réglage peut
dire méritage ousmane on comprend pas
terrible amériques de personnes
mécontentes de quelques toitures gestion
aussi même moi j'ai une table de mixage
chez moi je cours
bah voilà tu vois pas changer sur plus
tard
tous de france alors oui quelque chose
c'est qu'on parle pas football
aujourd'hui l'accord on voulait vous
souhaiter à tous la bienvenue peut pas
rêver mieux comme météo ce matin ça va
être cool relax m
[Musique]
go
on
on est vraiment en train d'être complété
je me suis dit m c'est incroyable c'est
un truc de fou
mr m
on a confié m mais quand rennes monte à
450 m 450 mètres des gens qui font ma
taille en barrant les routes de meo
benoît c'est trop bien il était en
caleçon une heure après bienvenue au
club franchement les a piégés au fn ou
voltaire c'est une terre usine en fait
c'est très silencieux plus apaisant il
est 7 heures et on est dans un ballon
pas pour se dire saint geours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'atterrissage mais des poignets ici on
attrape les poignées fléchit un peu les
jambes et on prie pour tout se passe
bien
d'abord cherché un même en actionnant
300 m de se poser avant de barbelés ici
au québec chaire c'est violent c'est
trop stressant
sandrine mesalamine doubs alors
regardons et la terre se rapproche du
protecteur des militaires furent traités
mal invasive tout ce que tu peux bien
fou c'était bon aussi mais je n'aime pas
cette province il a fait ça mais de main
de maître une énorme merde skvader
dessus mais la mer doivent ramer revient
devient truc émouvant de google mais
arrêtez de parler merde je me cardiaque
chier une énorme débat toi qui m'as
vidéo ça la balle et qu'on lui a prêtées
pour se départager 2-2 bon en amont on
va le faire on a kiffé c'était
incroyable c'est faux parce que cette
matinée j'ai fait plus que normand que
je fais en une semaine entière alors que
là il est vraiment neuf heures du matin
moi j'aimerais faire honneur à bonon
j'aimerais peut dire benoît ont cette
expérience
non non non
no way on va visiter un peu ça je n'ai
pas mal de choses notamment un enfant
que j'ai vu comment il s'appelle
maneguen fils c'est quoi l'histoire de
alors je tiens à plusieurs je vais
raconter la plus connue en fait il y
avait un immeuble caprio tout le monde
était paniqué et bah il a pissé sur le
feu et salles art et essai il a arrêté
le foil son urine combien de litres
d'eau il avait bu avant apparemment à 60
mille litres il avait vu c'est dans
l'allègement moi donc j'ai perchée ou 6
g perche et ben stiller bensi le recueil
et d'essilor c'était avec jean dujardin
c'était faux grand débarquement sur
canal j'ai perchée bat jonathan cohen
jonathan cohen avant qu'ils soient un
coup grave un côté un peu marrant alors
j'ai cherché aussi si friands si bien
c'est assez réduit
avec avec le cas exclusive j'ai perchée
bat également dégagé les knicks silva
tvn
j'ai cherché jackman s'est déjà dit j'ai
un petit cadeau pour toi ô c'est trop
mignon et amène sa te faire écouter bien
sûr on attend mais tu as 12 ans et une
masse de l'alcool mais quel est le
message qu'on transmet la mecque trop
bien sais pas si c'est bien aussi c'est
bizarre car refusant je rappelle l'abus
d'alcool et c'est pas bien après ce
cadeau votre coup j'étais c'est gagné
voilà mais on va faire un petit bowling
ensemble t bonds bling normalement à la
j'espérais tellement que tu fasses non
je suis pourri je suis dit
oui lucas il a l'air mon père la
compétition est vraiment envie de le
démonter la cie fois c'est bon parce
qu'il va avoir le moral à zéro
c'est bon pour moi tu vas le moral là
tout est une question de morale allez
deuxième essai à celle là elle est belle
bon j'ai cassé mon moral qu'avec l'appui
non
yes allez vas-y fais nous rêver
non mais vous désole le bonheur à
l'équipe de football des eaux et un
enfant brillant il a plein d'ambition
plein de joie de vivre et il a été très
inspirant pour toute l'équipe
elle m'a échappé des mains comme la
coupe a échappé aux belges mon passage
surprise la marque aimée sait pas à quel
point lui va marquer c'est peut être moi
non c'est à ceux là je vais t'acheter
une boisson et aucun point cette fois ça
je veux dire qu'une fois strike et je ne
dirais qu'une fois neoma rappeler qui a
longtemps j'étais comme lui un an font
plein de rêves et aujourd'hui grâce à
vous j'ai réalisé l'un d'eux alors je
dis peut-être trop mais merci merci
merci
voilà c'est pour ça va mieux j'ai cliqué
sur nouvelle partie comme un débile mais
je vous assure que jamais battus ce
petit nom et on a tous les deux étaient
nulles mais il a été plus mou avec moi
mais dirait bien que j'ai gagné ce match
de bowling à les strikes nombreux
l'espère encore plus les héros qui y
toucher encore plus si kraft n'a pas vu
ses huit auraient pas été fiers de nous
c'était génial séjourne avec vous quand
j'ai surkiffé c'est trop cool d'avoir
fait ça dit merci pour votre accueil
assez pour les petits cadeaux
bon pote c'était cool tu es trop bien
merci d'avoir envoyé un petit vidéo du
coup c'est oui merci beaucoup sur un
gamin aussi merci d'avoir été complice
est cool et il a bien tenu la surprise
et où c'était génial
et nous on part en guadeloupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis du sommes en guadeloupe nous
avons fait un petit surprise hakim de
revoir un schéma je suis content parce
que natsume manque beaucoup on vient
pour elle quand même avec son copain
robin un meilleur pote farah c'est eux
qui ont organisé les trous pour le faire
cette petite surprise je vois des gens
là bas
j'espère qu'on n'est pas griller vous
savez qu'on va se dépêcher c'est parti
on lâche tout en vidéo comment sarah et
ses lots il ya du monde salue le cas
comment tu vas obama et le chinois oui
tu m'as haut
j'ai bien sûr la tension est là on est
un petit programme qui oui je vais te
kidnappé vraiment on va partir dans une
chute d'eau dans la forêt après on va le
faire du jet ski est prête c'est y pas
beau ce ton chien rend ton chien aux
gens merci beaucoup je vais gérer
[Musique]
ims à jamais notre coco non on a fait
quel but
elle veut trouver le plaisir mais tout
ce qu'on fait là déjà fait parce qu'elle
est vraiment d'origine guadeloupéenne
donc elle connaît tous sa mère et à
chaque fois je lui dis tu as déjà fait
ça fait un an je suis content de le
faire aujourd'hui on a la taille est
peut être moins cher à tous les gens
savent tout cela
[Musique]
on va aux sodas coma où se trouve une
petite ascan finalement à pointe noire
congo d'où est ce que tu es déjà allé là
bas
oui alors on va changer de plan tout de
suite et on va aller au soda côté hier
se tenait ce deus et j'allais là-bas
c'est beau oui c'est sublime let's go
aux sodas comme a tout de suite
[Musique]
oh [ __ ] dans la proche
il va vous arriver au scandale comme en
plus on va aller là où parce qu'on peut
sauter ça sert exactement
ok on va faire le grand saut le petit
saut de france tu as déjà fait le grand
saut n'ont à première fois pour tous les
deux je propose d'y aller en essayant de
passe péter la gueule on essaye d'être
[Musique]
tout est toujours qu'un jour de la
mémoire et du jet qui va plaire au
sérieux il faut c'est une calvitie à
paris tu sais comment ça oui moi c'est
toi mais je veux qu'ils ne ratent aucun
problème ni au bourdeix exactement qui
se prend pour donner et attention pas
d'idée lcd
on va vers un petit coucher de soleil
trop bon boulot pour tout habitués moi
je suis un peu moins habitués et du coup
j'ai touché quoi j'ai vu des iguanes ce
soit il faut me wade je me fais
reprendre de partout j'en veux plus j'ai
vu des iguanes j'ai sauté dans l'eau
avec du poisson qui vient manger avec
une sorte de gommage gratuit c'était
magnifique les buts et on transpire et
très fort est vraiment bien faire son
métier
je lui fais un compliment c'est fou que
j'ai dit c'est bien sûr je suis battu su
tuer bientôt midi avec les avants son
taff et logistiques non une fois ya
longtemps il ya dix ans ok ça compte pas
chez moi j'en ai fait hier c'est bon
ça va avenant jeu lentilles avec les
gens et vous n'avez pas su c'est un peu
aberrant
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
nous
oh
kimmons sommes autour d'un feu on est
passé du disque et un feu on a rien
compris on avec tout ton cou et on va
faire du bruit à troyes 1 2 3 et au
wales est morte non vraiment c'était une
région de ouf les gens il se détend
jamais vu ça de ma vie il met 35 minutes
à trani compo cas vraiment eu conacoh
quatre à cinq jeunes femmes les 30
minutes côté je vais dans le feu c'est
bon j'ai bloqué surtout les iguanes les
iguanes
j'ai bloqué surtout les iguanes que j'ai
vu ici pour vous c'est basique ans est
fou de foot vous habitez vous faites
deux est un peu blasés
non alors là ça se voit rien
je vous reproche qu'on kiffe un taux
autour du feu trempe il termine la
guadeloupe sur ce monde incroyable
plaisir c'est trop bien merci à tous
ceux qui ont contribué à ça c'était
vraiment génial aussi beaucoup les amis
je reviendrai bientôt à dodig one
[Musique]
c'est dans ce décor de rêve que cette
belle journée pris fin on a longuement
échangé au bord de la mer et du feu de
camp dans une ambiance digne d'une
colonie de vacances
et franchement ça fait du bien
kim et ses amis étaient accueillants
chaleureux et hyper mal de vrais
guadeloupéen
les paysages de l'île vont manquer les
iguanes aussi je l'admets mais ça avec
de magnifiques souvenirs est un sourire
aux lèvres que je quitte la guadeloupe
et que je me dirige vers ma prochaine
destination montréal
[Musique]
les amis bienvenue à montréal la
guadeloupe c'était bien là gwada on a
kiffé on a vu plein de choses mais
aujourd'hui on passe un peu plus au nord
de la planète à montréal j'étais venu
l'année dernière à l'effet développe
avec clément on revient cette fois ci
pour faire une surprise à samuel qui a
je crois la vingtaine j'ai loué une moto
on va aller chercher en moto on va
d'abord faire la cuisine en sont mission
nacarat qui sait faire bien la cuisine
il va me coacher ses partir chez samuel
network
[Musique]
on est devant chez samuel on y va tout
de suite parce qu'il peut nous voir des
fans sc bastia vu comment ça va
j'aimerais bien on vient voir samuel oui
on est avec toute l'équipe
et puis alors passer une journée
ensemble je sors comme ça vous monte
l'assaut d'un tablier comme ils ont va
faire la cuisine c'est usain est donc
moindre but et ben non je sors à se
faire à manger c'est fini des livres ou
commander à manger c'est terminé je vois
d'essai le temps de te préparer à
l'évasion s'est habillé habille toi tout
ça et on y va
déjà été passager sur une moto ça fait
vraiment bien je te présente la streak
tripple sûr ça qu'on va aller à un petit
cours de cuisine se présente on casse
j'aurais un peu moins de style que la
semelle quand il passe depuis jama vie
de tous les jours il devient brad pitt
pas transition allait ben amos est trop
chou t'accroches à ma taille c'est le
moment peu viril pour toi
[Musique]
am je te présente le chef clément salut
france a salué - saint-vincent chanter
très peu et tu le saches temps d'être
nuls pas ma sfere dingue de toi
précision on est avec jeff qui est un
très bon ami de slam suis un peu toi
plus ou moins justes - où il va nous
aider à aller aujourd'hui c'est utile
tronçon de crevettes roses agrumes
ensuite en faire un anglais grillé sauce
béarnaise et on terminera avec une bombe
budgétaire au chocolat et puis compotée
de bananes au citron vert et fleur de
sel on va commencer tout de suite parce
qu'on appelle la banque d'une pièce avec
une genre de crème anglaise véritable
vous 3 à venir ici pour commencer la
préparation qui veut venir
samba this article ça me pression un peu
ok ça le ce côté je te préparer les
jaunes d'oeuf clarifier et tu vas venir
raclée tout ce qui est à l'intérieur
le lait la crème sont mis à bouillir
venir le verset dedans mais j'ai besoin
de tout futur ou encore rock et wet est
là pour bosser
allez vas-y 1 2 3 on y va doucement san
que tu prends bien t'inquiète pas je te
supporter je suis en train de penser à
mes fichiers et de deux il ya une étape
alors deuxième préparation je vais
prendre deux personnes en même temps
mais elle est légale et marc mais
n'aurait pas nous ensemble on va
commencer la terre de cacao on va
commencer à faire chauffer l'eau ici
vas-y et eu à verser la totalité du sud
[Musique]
l'aca travail et c'est là inséré sur ce
bras
de son côté l'ol se met à bouillir ouais
alors ta droite commence à remuer allez
vas-y donc toujours dans le même sens
inverse des aiguilles d'une montre et
pas vraiment sorti j'ai de le faire un
charbon esclaves j'adore ça témoin des
instruments mais si on voit que ça
commence à colorer dans sa casserole je
t'avais dit prix opus est avant toute
chose c'est le truc horrible un must et
là c'est plus compliqué que ça ouais
c'est ce que faisait m attendait des
garçons à prendre un paquet de recettes
pas faire un pas que ça c'est parti pour
la suite ça ils savent à suivre ça va
être un souci au montage mais en tout
cas ça sent bon
je pense que ça va être finalement une
friterie fond le vrai sens d'ouverture
d'une banane c'est de ce côté là et pas
de l'autre voilà une petite rixe
[Applaudissements]
en fait ce qu'il y a tout technique plus
d'églises ce programme
[Musique]
dès qu'il fait beau ça
temps
[Musique]
ça tourne c'est comme ça que tu casses
de traverse sans regarder on a perdu car
avec la porte regardez si martin il a
oublié la vidéo d'employés la liste des
bugs arif le énormément ici pour lui ce
que tu veux faire un petit point de la
situation
personne ne veut travailler ça me rend
fou on voit donc la solution qui se
passe c'est terrible car h te prends
pulsions théo ne réalise plus est en
train de craquer complètement s'est
rétréci la tournée on va faire de la
luge d'été dans un temps qui ne
représente pas du tout l'été j'en ai
fait une fois dans ma vie ces bruits et
le genou les freins ont lâché il a dû
freiner avec son genou contre le mur et
saignait très fort ouah ça donne envie
d'aller vers ça tout de suite
et juste après un parcours lumineux dans
la foulée s'appelle tongs alumina il y
en a pas beaucoup dans toutes les
structures donc j'espère pouvoir le
faire mais comme il pleut je ne sais pas
où aller
mme amos la laisse partir
[Musique]
solides devant de la scène dub band aid
les gars vous n'êtes pas fait on avec
toute l'équipe z on est éclatée pour la
fatigue on va faire de la luge
[Musique]
m
j'ai tellement bien les amis on est
fatigué il ya du jet lag et si on a un
doute la contagion qu'on en est
tellement mort parce que c'était prof sa
petite journée je kiffe votre ville
montréal c'était génial
les gars 5 à la jeune et la célèbre
roman comme prévu ont terminé la journée
au parcours tongs alumina malgré la
fatigue et au gros rythme du voyage j'ai
adoré et profiter de chacun des instants
passés aux côtés de samuel et jeff
montréal dégage une ambiance très
spécifique dans laquelle on se sent bien
et chaque québécois qu'ils parlent te
donne envie d'être son pote tellement il
est cool malheureusement la météo
n'était pas de notre côté mais ça nous a
pas empêchés de kiffer et d'apprendre
enfin à cuisiner autre chose que des
pâtes avec de l'emmental râpé
merci samuel merci à ta famille pour
l'accueil et j'espère vraiment qu'on se
reverra la prochaine fois que j'ai dans
ta ville
il est maintenant temps de prendre
l'avion direction l'autre côté du globe
la suisse
en suisse nous sommes à gland avec alice
qui est là on va aller voir les tisseurs
je n'ai pas au courant que je viens non
tu es dans le coup exactement fait sa
meilleure amie
et oui ça se passe bien toujours très
bien et sympa avec toi oui toujours
c'est bien on a bien fait choisi un
métis ya dans ce cas là c'est magnifique
de ta mission c'est de sortir laetitia
ma maison on fait ça allait bien c'est
parti justicialiste
[Musique]
tandis qu'anne-lise au sel c'est ici
laetitia quoi fait
la boue
[Musique]
m
ça va aller ça allait bien là on est
venu à gland d'entre eux ça va bien on
va faire plein de trucs aujourd'hui toi
et moi serait très rigolo temps ça va
toujours mieux on m'a dit oui à 11
heures il ya quelqu'un ici bien les
passagers plus jeunes et on est là on
est venu tout droit de montréal et là on
est tous mans d'équipé dead alors
programme riche explique voilier sur le
lac léman que tu connais bien mieux que
nous hélicoptère au dessus de la suisse
et tu connais bien le club et ensuite
cinéma en plein air tu connais possible
que nous y voilà très bien savoir mettre
à l'aise chez pas short et tout fait
très chaud chaud chaud
et oui j'arrive fait analyser mais bon
on va y aller let's go
[Musique]
sujet théo théo quand ils real pas et
prend des photos en cachette c'est vrai
la compote sonabhy quoi en fait un tu te
voir une grande photo pour le voyage à
leur cause de ma mère mais on a tout le
monde prenne avec lui désolé j'avais la
place qui prennent cette équipe ça mais
c'est terrible on aurait dû prendre que
martin tu vois ça je me dis ça pue des
besoins ou quoi
[Musique]
c'est ici à bienvenue sur un voilier
c'est une première pour moi
paul et c'est pas une première pour jp
notre ami qui va nous apprendre à
conduire cette chose comment on fait 10
nous commençons tout de suite par
redescendre le moteur et puis être une
personne pourra passer à l'avant pour
larguer les amarres martin tu veux le
faire comme ça tu fais ma claque à
marquer le temps tu le fais en première
personne d'asie beau gosse vallat
gintama
ta tombe à tous merci j'ai hâte de
travailler de se rendre là bas je prends
la barthez toile habitants olalala
tester le genre de questions que tu
poses mais tu pries bien qu'elle dise
non en fait je vais essayer de le faire
non plus à faire des jolies plantes à
rester plus stylé charismatique plus
musclée fin c'est toi qui dois le faire
plus bronzé aussi que tu as regardé
devant et tu vas essayer de rester face
au vent les amis il est temps maintenant
de travailler pour faire marcher le
voilier sans moteur alors faisons ça en
musique
[Musique]
nous sommes actuellement en train de
naviguer uniquement a souvent un peu
comme le père de ton père de la mère de
ton père c'est un peu comme la
montgolfière du coup y'a pas de bruit ça
fait du bien qui est pas de moteur quel
silence pour autant de l'eau voilà c'est
mon petit côté pieters la porte du pet
j'approuve je suis fait exceptionnel
sarralbe av
aïe aïe aïe aïe cas voire de l'extrême
[Musique]
e
où
laetitia on a apprécié ou pas très
apprécié on vole et maintenant on n'a
jamais cet avis jamais fait jamais de ta
ville jamais nulle part dans le monde
trop bien ça va être génial allez vas-y
même mois c'est parti
[Musique]
un hélico obama devrait conduire tout de
même la deuxième fois de ma vie que j'en
ai pas un match que bonjour en offrant
des prêts se voyait les débats
[Musique]
on n'est clairement pas fait pour être
dans les airs vous le dis les humains
chu a ouais nan mais dieu ou une heure
on faisait du bateau et d'avoir mon
discours pour des comptes comme la ligue
1 de la porte verte alors qu'il est
repassé au-dessus commence à enrouler
autour de l'île correct il a dû mouiller
son caleçon un polo mais qu'il est ce
fichier dessus je crois qu'on va passer
voilà où les biens votes déposés en
hélico chez toi les messieurs les deux
pas des incroyables dit avant moi je
suis subjugué quoi ah ouais nan mais si
j'ai fait à nouveau passé devant j'ai
l'impression d'être dans un vaisseau
spatial les gars incroyable
ah que c'est beau la montagne que ce
point de vue plus tard hallucinant
ce fut un moment des blasés de cartons
non
[Musique]
alors les commerces étaient pas à tuer
un très beau pays je te le dis que tu le
saches j'ai réalisé à quel point le lac
léman est immensément grand en fait
vraiment un moment de ouf
et puis maintenant on va redescendre un
peu on va se poser devant un petit film
en extérieur ici ensuite on va chacun
rentre chez soi dormir jusqu'à demain et
demain peut-être un autre tube heure
viendra tout est chez toi on va se poser
ouais allez c'est parti cette journée
s'est finalement terminée comme beaucoup
d'autres en regardant un film
sauf que là les conditions étaient
optimales faut l'avouer la journée était
folle est clairement je pouvais pas
rêver mieux comme première fois en
suisse
laëtitia était grave content à 18 ans
elle se pose les mêmes questions que moi
au même âge
et pourtant c'était il ya quatre ans
elle traverse une période que j'ai pas
connue celle où on peut trouver son
chemin est sûr que c'est le bon elle a
réussi à le trouver alors j'espère
qu'elle ira jusqu'au bout et qu'elle
aura la vie professionnelle qu'elle
souhaite
[Musique]
regard des gens qui dansent tous go
franchement non
ethisphere c'est parmi les moustiques
que je me dise au revoir
j'ai eu un record de piqûre pour moi
c'était trop cool ces petits tours
d'hélico ce petit voilier ce petit ciné
cette petit fils je puis me permettre
bonne culture et sur l'un des études
plein de bonnes choses merci à très vite
en suisse oui j'étais dit revoir merci
laetitia c'est trop cool merci beaucoup
merci
direction marseille pour nous c'est
parti
[Musique]
ces poteaux découvert un jour là qu'un
seul c'est le douzième 2e 13e rang du
classement 15e à 14 30 millièmes
ressenti 38 m
[Musique]
bienvenue à marseille l'une des plus
belles villes de france c'est vrai ou
pas merci il est actuellement de 7 tours
s'est levé à 6h30 pour faire une petite
surprise
inès aujourd'hui c'est sa maman qui est
complice n'est pas sa meilleure amie ça
va être rigolo c'est parti on va
rejoindre ines elle est dans l'un de ces
immeubles c'est pas le cas lorsqu'il ya
peu vous dire le gall c'est ok allez on
va chercher on y va c'est toujours la
phase compliquée on doit pas être vue on
se chie dessus des du moment on a six
victoires sur 6 1 ça fait chier qu'à une
défaite car je crois qu'on va aller par
là bas n'a jamais autant gagné bon
galère un peu à trouver les meubles
apparemment c'est juste derrière moi la
voix va être cramé
tu vois ce petit stress là c'est bout ça
ignoré par interpol on va sonner au smic
c'est juste du gras
dans les quartiers
comment ça va et ness cordura viala soir
on s'est levés tôt pour toi tu sais ça
et là si ça nous a fait très très mal un
dimanche c'est ta maman la surprise est
ici on a une grosse journée de dominer
ce qu'on va faire du cheval pas du fait
de cheval et ben tu vois on referme un
grand ouverts tournés alors site on va
aller dans la merde avec des masques des
tubas pour voir un peu les bêtes
queuille alors ça doit faire du skate
j'ai un peu ce qui est tu as dit tu vas
en refaire bon bah merci ça m'ira c'est
trop cool et puis on va faire une
journée trop bien
[Musique]
allez c'est parti
eh bien tu as fait c'est trop stylé
l'oiseau qui vient toquer c'est
hallucinant ramé nous réveille le matin
9h30 incroyable merci
[Musique]
côté né ici et wind exemple non ça
dépend si on les nerfs on est comme ça
wen et mars ici on noie les bars et
franchement des gros concours sont là où
on est beau merde arrachement un
paisible au psg ils ont bien [ __ ] l'om
a way à la truite à tous et très cher
c'est que j'ai mon galop 3 ans cheval je
fais des colos de cheval quand j'avais
onze ans que le mouvement du bateau
c'est que tout le monde sache quoi ça
mais je suis pas fragile bon c'est ma
maman qui a mis dans des colonies de
cheval quand j'étais petit hoquet toi tu
sécher les cours là en sarouel affirmé
db2 moi j'allais en colonie de cheval
stimulent et de quoi plus court toujours
mon gars on va dans un range ses champs
mais c'est à dire revenu net ici non
c'était pas la caf et du cheval ya dix
ans c'est trop bien mec j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans red dead
redemption deux mâles et
[Musique]
ce que tout va bien il s on n'est pas
malin ambronay si tu mets un coup talons
pour accélérer et tu tires sur la laine
sur freiner mais pourquoi trop le cheval
ça faisait des années que j'en avais pas
fait la chaleur est les beaux paysages
de marseille font plutôt plaisir on va
pas se mentir les moustiques un peu
moins par contre ont galéré un peu à
parler avec inès parce qu'on devait
gérer nos chevaux et le sien avait du
caractère manga à un délire et nice
était assez discrète parce que je pense
qu'elle réalisait toujours pas ce qui
venait de lui arriver
mais comme toutes les autres il s était
d'une gentillesse incomparable elle m'a
donné envie de donner le meilleur de
moi-même pour qu'au quotidien à travers
mes vidéos je puisse apporter un peu de
bonheur à ces journées d'étudiants qui
parfois peuvent être compliquées allez
hop la chaleur ça dégage live étant
passé l'activité un peu plus fraîche si
l'on retrouve et déshydratés aurait
inès dont je me l'étais l'an il faut les
pas du tout avancé
il était un peu têtu j'ai les mains
brûlées genre ah ouais ça tue les jambes
et coup on va annuler la journée à
partir de là tu l'as l'épongé selon moi
je vais bien
bon on change de milieux moi je trouve
qu'il fait chaud sa mère à marseille
c'est pas qu'une réputation c'est vrai
en fait souhaiter habitués mais nous on
n'est pas du tout habituée à chaud quand
même alors imagine pour des par exemple
pas l'habitude et donc on va s'accrocher
on va aller dans l'eau avec des masques
des pannes des tubas et des combi et on
va voir les petits animaux marins on
aura une gaufre chacun pourra filmer ce
qu'on voit et tout ça va être rigolo
c'est parti sur la tournée va la sauver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les nations avec tonic et à nos vies
entre ses mains
il ya des mots kalou pas un peu ok ça
commence bien c'est que je me faisais
tout le matériel
ok alors moi j'ai un problème avec les
tubas j'ai fait une fois du tuba dans le
lac de brûlures et me sentais très fort
le gars anecdotes et j'ai fait une
moyenne pendant un cache cache donc en
plus des hôtes ont failli voir puisque
j'ai tout fait déjà n'y a pas trop de
quelqu'un après ça ira plus clean que le
lac de boulogne à bout du bâton comme ça
il va plutôt derrière la tête
quand tu regardes en on voit se retrouve
quasiment à la perpendiculaire de la
surface de l'eau truc du masque est
indispensable de faire avant de partir
pour cracher dedans bien étalée sur les
vite sinon ça à faire de la pub c'est
bon ouais on sait qui fait la mode
tél
tout est au moins aussi top
on est bien la question est bien mais je
me sens fort mauvais je deviens mairie
mais qu'on annule la vidéo la scène
[Musique]
à
un concombre de mer ça fait vive enfin
pourquoi petit paul simon notamment oui
la giclette à trauma et tout est fourni
avec alou voilà
[Rires]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà les battles donc du coup j'ai peur
d'une insolation vous l'aurez compris
c'était compliqué de filmer dans l'eau
mais j'ai donné le meilleur de moi-même
pour avoir ces plans incroyables
bon ok il puait la mer des plans j'ai
lutté monga contre ma thalasso phobie
pour observer avec kenneth le monde
marin et franchement j'ai kiffé c'est
fou comme en fait quand on nage on se
rend pas compte de tous les êtres
vivants qui nous entourent ont cessé
chez on est montés sur nos skate et on a
pris la direction du port pour terminer
la journée dans les meilleures
conditions
[Musique]
oh
as tu aimais plongée ouais j'ai réussi à
manier un tuba paulo pour cache-cache 2
on pourra retourner dans un acte cette
fois je serai bien caché il fait oui de
la tête
les gardes et bientôt la fin du voyage
suppute inde et mu là c'était où cette
journée avec toi à marseille j'étais pas
venu ici depuis 10 ans et à aimer j'ai
trop aimé j'ai pas vu le centre ville le
port et tous ces chants mais la petite
surprise de l'oiseau je te cache pas
j'en ai paraître la journée dont j'ai
trouvé ça mignon when the selecter
incroyable cet oiseau très bon la
lumière est trop trop belle ça fait
penser à un certain jet ski en
guadeloupe je trouve ici a eu des bonnes
vagues comme en guadeloupe ou moins bon
petit soirée ici sur ce bateau avec
l'équipe pour fêter l'avant dernière
destination et derrière ça au maroc
merci mais c'était trop coincé à train
puis une bonne chose en cette étude
merci puis continuerait cette foison les
amis l'équipe est en train de se poser
théo fait sa petite pause la dic au
dessus de travailler parce qu'il adore
travailler c'est pas ça ce métier en
fait un message entendent montrer aux
gens que c'est pas simple du tout et que
les mecs se tape une gamme de cartes
philo aussi forte sur les épaules c'est
abusé attends je fais la focus le plan
il est magnifique ce on inverse les
rôles je filme l'équipe technique est là
à l'extension de ce plaisir c'est un peu
une soupe chaude
hall a lâché une belle image de paulo 20
mecs j'ai cadré 1,2 milliard de ce que
tu as fait ça m'a cassé les couilles
allez je récupère mon métier tu
récupères le tir
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue ici au maroc à marrakech je
parle pas fort parce qu'on a un côté de
notre prochaine cible est la dernière du
voyage
je suis très émue s'est luxé la fin
qu'on finit au maroc en beauté je t'ai
jamais venu chez treasure ya le papa de
riz tard il ya 17 ans
sympa le papa à la fille à 17 ans lui
l'un des open on va faire une petite
surprise à rita va aller la voir de
suite on se doute de rien comme
d'habitude maintenant je vous donne ici
c'est la huitième fois mais surtout on
commence à connaître et je crois qu'on a
réussi un bel grillé jusqu'à l'assemblée
ça c'est beau elle est bien partie
[Musique]
comment ça va c'est un paquet dans le
coup c'est pardon tu chantes si tu
chantes rite c'était bien tu est la
dernière personne qu'on vient voir oui
on fait explique pas dire en temps réel
sinon c'était pas alors je te présente
l'équipe on regarde ici on à karachi qui
prend le soleil tu connais maintenant à
estoril a connu la ja vlad
ici il ya martin et là on va faire des
actions sont aujourd'hui on va aller
faire du chameau et du buggy alors si
donc on a un petit et tu sais que c'est
ça ouais ça moi je peux toucher la
maigreur hélas rien ça peut être que moi
qui il est bon très hockey et il est
encore mieux en vrai ouais ok ok c'est
bien un produit qui n'était pas du tout
ok mais je me vexe pas tu vois mais bon
après tu es bien de toi et tu dis on va
voir tahri elle est la maman
côté ballet à tout à [ __ ] ithaca des
liens directs j'adore ces trois titres
et nous aussi c'est la dernière
fatigué ouest utah palette wattret je me
fais de resté muet dans cette vidéo je
fais ça tu as dit un coup dur ce n'est
pas cool maintenant cool bon allez on va
rire toute la journée c'est évident
surprise à squeeze et là on va ramener
faire plein d'activités spéciales
[Musique]
tu viens moi est ce que je sais pas je
connais que star foule soit on doit
arrêter s'il vous plaît le perdre et je
suis sûr qu'aujourd'hui il va prendre
il répète après mont houy salamone
coutts à la vallée mythique we ce
mythique wapiti squeeze métier rappelé
hutues spasmes été squizzée visite à 10
juste m'amuser suis très content d'être
bloqués voilà pour tous les marocains
on est là parce que vous avez fait
honneur ouais ça se trouve c'est squeeze
je déteste les instituts m'a fait venir
sans faille des rigolos était bien là tu
fais quoi t'as vu une telle nous sympa
tableau comment s'appelle ali n'ont pas
le mec la torah est ce que tu peux
expliquer ce que c'est une gamme doit
pas du tout passé moment d'introduire
l'homme et dont la tenue est ce que je
vais vous dire ce que c'est ça marche
bien c'est bien et ça plus long d'europe
quand aulas et ses trucs traditionnel
pour les femmes le blanc c'est pour les
saints moi je met sa toiture
mais non mais non il viendra sur les
femmes soient pas en avoir et attention
moi je suis ski d'innovation mais sa
martingale axa et moi je vois la mienne
avec ce qu'elle est c'est parti à temps
mais c'est du xl attention humiliation
dans 3 2
sais tu vas tu es peu sincère je vois
que tu es peu sincère et attend ça c'est
pas toi allez tu parles mais tient bon
doit s'en aller
[Applaudissements]
vidéo d'accord bah tiens rien sympa non
mais c'est comme ça partager à dos et on
doit mettre des casques c'était quelque
chose comme ça prix magic de marocains
parce que comme ça on dirait un saoudien
par contre là on va changer le nom tu
peux pas d'appeler lucas légalement john
meyer brahim brahim m'annoncer plus le
cas après bahreïn
qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé et tout ça
c'est arrivé en deux minutes près même
pas eu le temps de ton président ibrahim
sportive est ce que tu me dépasse je
klaxonne vont prévenir du départ laisse
moi faire je suis pas naïve je connais
mon métier à tout de suite dans le buggy
ou pas ou peut-être des morts on sait
pas on imposer ça mais on est bien mais
comment arrivez vous à gérer ce parti on
a beau nous dit on va vous évoquez
bonne idée
un passager dans le train de manger du
sable
on est bien dans la bouche mais pas
forcément au top mais ils n'avancent pas
encore vive la fête
le latéral
il est à wasquehal
j'ai des bleus partout rita on a fait
des bleus vient il ya marché aurait pu
marcher non d'un seul coup c'est ce
style c'est génial est ont payé très bon
la partie non menotté de ton pays et
souhaite aussi belle que la partie
habitée est entiché complément au
paraguay
ici une tradition c'est bon à jeter à
bas oui vous êtes là vous savez dit
mohammad ibrahim najjar est pas moi j'en
mets partout avec commande à l'été comme
ça et peut-être moins et du coup ça fait
se lever la voix j'ai fait des bruitages
mars avril
brahim non c'est plus quizy c'est brahim
hockey jeunes entrepreneurs du marlois
il vient dans le youtube guy allaire et
tabac mois ci hu
or en direct dans le coeur du sujet
s'est servi ouais il faut le remettre
bonjour bien mélanger le truc je peux
ainsi pente c'est pour la mousse d'oeuf
et ont stoppé direct et les gouttes faut
être sûr que c'est un empoisonneur sinon
merci dieu va et vient dire il ya du
poisson à suivre donc il leur fait un
comment on dit il a l'air bon et je le
tente de le dire km ben dites bendit a
partagé sa marque à 5 à tes sacs
oui oui merci chaque rame de chacun
merci bonjour je vous crache l'analogie
je flâne à la magie non mais oui il ya
didier de rien n'indique géante 1.2.1
début avertit noisy et c'est ok
jack a dull comment il trouve très très
bon le thé les gars il est colossal
alors oui c'est son affaire vas-y fut
ensuite sera en france et à peu près de
rabat le dromadaire
quand la femme et le bébé bon en tout
cas le programme éclair car elle montre
que les arbitres du barrage il est
excusé mais tu dis comme ça qu'elles
surprennent aussi est désolé d'apprendre
visite un petit quoi il est temps pour
nous de voir le thé au câble ont fait
une petite sieste et après pour ma merde
avec le coucher de soleil
[Musique]
les galas et barroso
c'est pas bon le petit et la petite
cérémonie dansante exact est sympa
apparemment ils voulaient nous marier
quand même ouais j'ai remarqué ça c'est
pas très réglo quand même par contre il
aurait dû appeler ce gros madère carrie
apparemment il est majeur c'est lui je
te jure que la lune de miel est vrai
alors été facile et bon on va tout de
suite finie azéri vient d'inventer un
très beau verbe on va tout de suite dans
mad errer dans le désert d'agassa y et
j'en ai jamais fait peut-être tunisie
une fois non je n'ai jamais vu en vrai
j'y allais mais je crois dans fan
m'intéresse
les gars on va faire du dromadaire je
suis a expliqué aujourd'hui il lui fait
une surprise ils aggravent qui fait si
vous allez on y va
what a pris un tour de confiance et
légendaire est grave c'est quoi donne
moi tes études et aussi on a chacun nos
enfants écoutent pas mal
[Musique]
what the fuck
ouah c'est bizarre j'ai besoin d'être
sur une monture dans un jeu à désolé
t'embêter je pense c'était mon stock ses
limites il nous semble pas nombreux
parents les selles c'est beaucoup plus
posé que le cheval pour être oui là
c'est qu'on port de dahouët c'est
conforme est qu il n hésite pas tu
prends la perche tu parles c'est la
france
il est au calme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait quoi devenir demain à paris ça
fait très mal au cul soit je te dise
d'autre
c'est ce que je voulais entendre ça fait
plus mal au cul que le cheval à
marseille
[Musique]
rita toutes les bonnes choses ont une
fin
est ce que ces moments tristes et pour
nous c'est encore plus triste pas si
c'est la fin du voyage
une fille de 10 ans qui m'a plu et je
suis pas bien je me sens mal c'est comme
ci joint un dromadaire pleurer tu vois
je suis pas exactement c'était trop bien
cette journée sera incroyable j'étais
jamais venu au maroc et ba et ba [ __ ]
de merde je sais pas pourquoi tu aurais
dû venir plein de fois c'est rita ouais
je la connais bien et en plus l affaire
du stand-up ce que savait pas c'est que
elle est extrêmement amusant de faire
maintenant vous savez et 1 passe et 1 %
de ce qui est dans la vraie vie
rita bien là merci monsieur propre but 1
allait bien j'étais trop bien merci
merci
j'étais trop génial tu un pays génial si
tes parents sont géniaux mr mercier où
tu ne trouves à chaque fois mais c'est
quoi comme au sein du groupe et merci à
squeeze de nous voila voila je veux
parler de rigueur
il a fait une tour pour venir nous voir
et je trouve ça extrêmement beau merci
encore une fois merci à vous soit d'un
petit à petit vidéo et merci de nous
avoir accueillis comme ça une femme
c'était fou quand tu veux mon pote tu
est dispo la semaine prochaine il vient
d'où là bas pas manger trop salé
non mais non on va aller caresser
question raconte sont pas les manger on
ne peut pas du tout on va manger des
buggy ça y est on va caresser de trop
on va nous en fait parce que les bornes
ou ses débuts c'est un peu des miss
c'est une fin tournage pour toute
l'équipe bravo et voilà c'est terminé
c'est sous le soleil du maroc que mon
voyage de 18 jours s'achève j'ai
découvert des cultures j'ai vu toutes
sortes de paysages et surtout j'ai
rencontré des personnes formidables
en bref pendant ce voyage j'ai obtenu
les plus beaux souvenirs d'une vie je me
rends compte plus que jamais qu'au delà
des pseudo c'est des vrais êtres humains
qui regardent les vidéos et que j'ai
pouvoir de redonner de la force que de
les aider au quotidien alors que je les
connais même pas c'est dingue sérieux
alors william charlène mais ho kim
samuel laetitia inès écrite à merci
merci car cette fois c'est vous qui
m'avez donné de la force
merci de m'avoir aidé à vivre cette vie
atypique est fantastique merci pour ces
journées à vos côtés et surtout merci
pour cette leçon de vie que je viens de
me prendre dans la gueule je vous
souhaite le meilleur à vous et aussi à
toi qui regarde cette vidéo car tout ça
tout ce que je vis aujourd'hui c'est
grâce à toi merci je crois que c'est bon
j'ai dit à cette fois dans la vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut exclusif le bibliobus qu'on
aimerait c'est passablement avec toi que
j'ai vraiment fort envie de te voir
je suis la future sem de natsu je suis
un grand fan de jeux vidéo un manteau
est surtout ne change rien du en voici
deux candidatures et j'espère de voir un
jour